it's not a gorilla sir it's
it's Mr Dilly and I would have succeeded
it hadn't been for these meddling kids
for decades Saturday mornings on CBS and
the other two major broadcast networks
were dominated by animated cartoons and
live action series Geared for children
changed in the late 1990s when the
Network's popular morning news programs
expanded into the weekends for us that
meant the 1997 debut of CBS News
Saturday morning and welcome back to CBS
News Saturday morning with co-host Russ
Mitchell and Susan Molinari coming to
you from the historic CBS broadcast
Center this is the way we're going to go
if you want a flat stomach okay A Change
came two years later the Saturday early
show premiered from a new studio across
the street from Central Park okay which
one of you can double dutch you can do
it with its own Plaza for outdoor
segments
three two one and you're done
fast forward 12 years it was back to the
broadcast Center as CBS This Morning
Saturday came on the air welcome to CBS
This Morning Saturday for seven years
Anthony Mason hosted the program with a
variety of co-hosts because you have
brought Bourbon and biscuits and in 2018
when the table expanded from Two Hosts
to three Michelle and I took our spots
and Jeff glor on his maiden voyage
Saturday run how's it going fun a year
later Jeff glor joined our Trio it's
really smooth one thing people hear
spicy when they think when they hear Rye
but it wasn't always smooth sailing this
is a first for our show at least I'm
Michelle all three of us are staying
distant during last year's covet
lockdown we and other networks did
something new in TV news welcome hosting
the show remotely from our own living
rooms thankfully we were able to return
to the studio last September but it
wasn't for long with the first time we
were all together at this table in
nearly half a year five and a half
months can you believe it as of today we
usher in a new era with CBS Saturday
morning coming to you from our exciting
new location the state-of-the-art studio
1515 in the Viacom CBS building right in
the heart of Times Square
Thanks for the Memories
it's pretty fun
action was great
um it's crazy look at some of those old
Cliffs right the coveted hair
that too yes covet hair for you Michelle
and I looked beautiful well I gotta
admit something I was gonna go gray
completely gray and so I did and then I
kind of got out of it all right things
you learn on this program you never
thought you would learn so